okay welcome to another duel
comment your video let's go well I go
for 4d for opening a searches that
suggested this in a currently running
serious offer abattoir for white go play
the same ish line just as I mentioned in
the videos b6 is pretty rare here
okay just continue with some normal
development
okay nerds interesting position where to
put the night I could go to e2 but I'm
not sure I like C 5595 I actually go
here so in this position he might get 95
in but then I can just retreat to e2 and
put the knight on f2 which looks like a
decent setup okay maybe he wants to play
b5 as a pawn sacrifice after all it's
not really really dangerous if he do if
he does but I'd like to prevent it
nevertheless h5 yeah okay I'm queen
belongs here anyway okay let's reroute
this one
yeah the problem with a black setup a
thing is that it's it's hard to to do
anything active here without playing e6
at some point and this b6 Bishop e7 and
so on really lost some time in regards
of a six-man we play a six and take on
d5 the bishop is just bet on b7 so black
has lost lots of time here okay I think
it's logical to get rid of the bishop
which is blacks best piece in the long
run
okay let's just take it okay well blacks
only idea here this may be b5
I don't think he 6s attractive anymore
after the bishop is has gone and whites
planets pretty easier we're just and I
just want to smash through with f4 and
e5 and for some even an idea immediately
hmm do I want to play h3 first - to
prevent him Najee form the play h3 I
just threaten f4 not sure what what he
will play then I think this looks good
oh I wanted to play h3 definitely
therefore nice I didn't intend therefore
it's not bad I just want to play I
wanted to play h3 and then okay I need
to speed up a bit here though
yeah it's really have been better I
think
okay now maybe five immediately D if I
if I just take here and take e5 some
would be would be great I think yeah
let's go here five this also has got the
idea of playing east six possibly and
really destroy blacks king's position
okay
yeah
yeah this is very nice for white not
sure what the best term plan is let's
just push this back to h6 only issue
will be the time maybe another idea
would have been to to take here and take
on d6 because he needs to take with the
Queen then okay
no.6 to to really push black back ends
now I need to need to open this position
up maybe maybe even g4 immediately
because blacks coordination is really
bad at the moment okay let's go for this
if it if it's not working I'll blame it
on the fact that I didn't have breakfast
yet
the idea now is if he takes h3h GFG
yeah let's let's see if we get get to
this I will play even f5 then okay
okay g5 it needs to go there right take
now and now look h1 coming up I just
need to exchange stuff here because the
bishop is dead
on b7 so if I get to exchange some
pieces this is almost automatic win okay
you can try to go to f5
no h2 is hanging
Queen is freaking I wants to go there
okay
better better go back yeah it will be
tricky with the time of course
Queen f7 to get rid of the Queen
I'm not sure if I manage this in 22
seconds so really completely winning
no no the pawns are just dropping 94 to
f6 to d6
oh I really got myself into trouble
again okay next game coming up